Okay, first things first. Once we've started to receive this HTML,
we'll be parsing it as we get it. So that's step one.
DOM construction can be incremental, and the response may not arrive all at
once. So, we may not finish constructing it all at once. In the head,
we'll find links to CSS and JavaScript, so then we'll fire off those requests.
That's step two. But there's a gotcha. The script is synchronous, and
we can't execute it until we have the CSSOM. So we'll need to create the CSSOM
as soon as possible. Completing the CSSOM will unblock the JavaScript engine, so
we'll be able to execute JavaScript as soon as we've received it.
Once the JavaScript is finished, we can resume and finish constructing the DOM.
Once we have the DOM and CSSOM, we'll merge the two and
build the Render Tree. After that, we run layout and paint the page.